Aww yeah! I'm so excited for today's lesson,
because we're learning with one of my favorite
singers Sia. So we're going to look at a
couple interviews with her and then we'll learn
with a couple of her popular songs. And if you
just want one or the other then you can skip to
whatever part you want using the chapters feature
down below. Now you might notice that her accent
is a little bit special, that's because Sia
comes from Australia, but she's been living
in the United States for so long that it is
really soft, so you might not even notice that.
And finally if you're a really
big fan of Sia like I am,
then you're not going to want to miss out on the
extra lesson that we have over on our Instagram,
with another one of her popular songs.
So now let's jump in!
Alright, so now we will continue with another
interview with Sia, where you actually get to
see her face, but quickly before we do I want to
let you know that if you are new here every single
week we make fun lessons, just like this one, to
help you understand fast speaking natives, just
like Sia, without getting lost, without missing
the jokes and without subtitles. Like Emil,
who says that thanks to our videos and our Fluent
with Friends Course, he has greatly improved
his English vocabulary, pronunciation and even
grammar. And you will too, it's really simple:
hit that Subscribe button and the Bell down below,
so you don't miss a single one of our new lessons.
All right, so Sia is actually trying her hand at
film. She recently directed a movie
called Music, which is coming out in 2021.
By the way, if you find it confusing when
natives speak like this, then I highly
recommend you try our 3-Part Masterclass. Now
in addition to tips for how to learn vocabulary
and understand the jokes, we will teach you how
to understand natives when we speak really fast
and connect our speech, just like
you've seen here. It's absolutely FREE
and you can learn more and sign up by clicking
up here or down the description below.